hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in chapter 7 of his treaties on the
anger of God locked hancius is going to
make a sort of brief discursis into a
really Central philosophical problem
that has been discussed throughout the
ages before him and after him and it's
this what is the nature of human beings
by contrast or perhaps even by
opposition to other animals and so the
chapter is actually titled on human
beings and brute animals brute meaning
those lacking speech reason and then
it's titled or religion
religione right so religion is going to
play a really Central role in this
discussion but first we start out by
thinking about you know the topic more
broadly and he says that that
philosophers no matter how goofy crazy
their ideas are no matter how poorly
equipped they are for figuring these
things out like he says though
philosophers have often turned aside
from reason through their ignorance of
the truth and fallen into inextricable
errors that is likely to happen to
Travelers ignorant of the way not
confessing that they're ignorant none of
them are so ignorant as to say that we
human beings are just animals like every
other animal we differ in some important
way or ways from the other animals
and then like tancius goes on from this
and he says there's actually something
divine within us human beings and what
is that well he brings up a couple
things and probably the most interesting
one of which is he says that there's an
affinity a Coke nazio a being related
between us and the Divine God in terms
of possessing the virtues of the soul
and the mind right so it's it's our
moral capacities you could say and our
intellectual capacities that make us not
the same as God but not even close to
God but at least
more like God than the other animals
then he brings up an argument that is at
best you know
what could we say confirming it's not
one that would really hold up on its own
and I personally don't consider it
particularly on point argument but you
know he says that does not the position
of the body itself are being upright
standing on two legs and the fashion of
the countenance the face right the the
uh form of it uh doesn't this actually
signify to us or declare that we are not
on a level what the dumb Creation The
Brute animals their nature is prostrated
to the ground into their pasture and has
nothing in common with the heaven which
they do not look upon
okay yeah I mean animals crawl around on
you know four or six or whatever number
of legs uh some of them don't crawl
around at all because they don't have
arms and legs like oysters
you know is the fact that we stand erect
and can look at the heavens
does that really separate us a lot from
the other animals I don't think that's a
very good argument but he does make that
and then he moves on to things that are
a little bit more uh plausible he says
that you know because of this erect
position and we compare our features
with God now we could do this while
we're sitting down we could do this
while we're lying down right
um so we actually as he says reason
recognizes reason and cognoskit from
cognosuke is the the word there to see
something of ourselves you know or
something like ourselves in God and and
vice versa right the other animals don't
appear to engage in that sort of
activity and we could also say I mean we
recognize
similarities between us and other
animals as we're going to talk about in
a bit so he asks then well what is
peculiar what is propria in the Latin
what is specific
to human beings as opposed to other
animals right and we could go through
all sorts of other interesting features
but he starts to zero in on the things
that philosophers typically talk about
now
so speech ceremo being able to
communicate with each other okay that
seems distinctive doesn't it I mean
animals have communication but they
don't actually have words do they and
produce sentences and write books about
that that sort of thing well he says
that
um
you know a lot of these things that
appear to be peculiar to to human beings
speech appears to be peculiar to human
beings but in this there's a certain
resemblance uh it's a speech on the part
of the other animals why they
distinguish one another by their voices
when they're angry they send forth a
sound resembling altercation when they
see one another after an interval of
time they show the office of
congratulation by their voice right to
us their voices appear uncouth or you
could say unformed inarticulate as ours
perhaps do to them but to themselves who
understand each other those are words
right so he says in every affection they
utter distinct expressions of Voice by
which they may show their state of mind
and you know given what we know now
about animals as well they communicate
with each other not just through voice
but through bodily posture through other
things like pheromones you know so
commune education not unique to human
beings we don't really understand animal
communication they understood it much
less in locktances this time but it's
enough for him to say yeah that's not
what makes us distinctively
what we are distinctively human what
about and you might say well where's
this coming from laughter well this was
another thing that was viewed very often
as a proprium a specific feature of
human beings we have a sense of humor we
laugh about stuff we play jokes and so
he says
true but we see certain indications of
joy in other animals when they use
passionate gestures with a view to
playing hang down their ears contract
their mouth smooth their forehead relax
their eyes to sportiveness right so they
they engage in something kind of like
laughter and showing humor right what
about reason okay so this is where
philosophers are typically going to go
right we are the rational animal that is
the distinctive thing about us and
lactancius is actually going to say
reason razio and planning for the future
Providencia this is definitely unique to
human beings right
and he says well no there are animals
which open several outlets in different
directions from their layers so if any
danger comes upon them an escape may be
open for them shut in but they wouldn't
do this unless they possessed
intelligence and reflection isn't it
interesting a lot of philosophers would
attribute that just to Instinct ah they
just know what they're doing lockdancius
is willing to say no they're thinking
about this they they plan it out they
actually adjust to circumstances right
he goes on and he says others are
actually Provident for the future look
at bees right uh or ants the sort of
common animals that that furnished
examples of social creatures right and
he goes and he says it would be a long
task if I traced out the things most
resembling the skill of the human being
which are accustomed to be done by the
separate tribes of animals but they do
do them so
maybe we do a better but they're not
unique to human beings so what what
actually is unique to us here he says
religion religio the acknowledgment and
worship and connection to something
Divine something greater than us and you
know he says this a little bit earlier
on that this is uh the the thing that is
unique to us and then he goes on here
and he says
um religion is the only thing of which
no Trace no neck vestigium Ali quote can
be found in other animals now it's up to
us in the present given what we know
about animal behavior to say is that
really true or not certainly in his time
there wasn't a lot of evidence for
Animals engaging in anything that
resembles religion and so he is willing
to say this is what is really unique to
us human beings and and this is tied in
with our not just knowledge of God but
our connection to God our uh distance
similarity to God and it's also
connected with Justice and wisdom
being unique to human beings here he
says something very strong
Justice is peculiar to religion and to
this no other animal attains human being
alone Bears rule the other animals are
subjected to him so there's a typical
you know Christian worldview actually
not just Christian and the stoics also
held something similar that the rational
creation is uh above the irrational
creation which exists for its its sake
and he says the worship of God is
ascribed to Justice he who does not
Embrace this being removed from the
nature of the human being will live the
life of the brutes but we differ from
the other animals almost in this respect
alone we perceive the Divine might and
Power in the others there's no
understanding of God understanding is
the key thing there right it's surely
impossible that the dumb animals should
have more wisdom or human nature should
be unwise since all living creatures in
the whole system of nature are subject
to the human being that account of
wisdom so reason if reason if the force
of man in this respect excels and
surpasses the rest of living creatures
in as much as he alone is capable of the
knowledge of God it's evident that
religion can in no way be overthrown now
can there is like the shouldn't be
because the next passage after that the
next chapter is those epicureans are
going to overthrow religion right so
obviously it is possible to some extent
to do that now later on in chapter 12
he's going to come back to this theme
it's called of religion and the fear of
God and he says that if religion is
taken away neithered wisdom nor Justice
can be retained they all kind of hang
together as being part of this complexes
that is what is truly distinctive to us
human beings where we are different than
the rest of the animals and in some
respect connected with or in a Affinity
with God why is this the case he says
that wisdom because the understanding of
the divine nature in which we differ
from the brutes found in human beings
alone right Justice because of us God
who cannot be deceived restrains our
desires we're going to live wickedly and
impiously therefore that our actions
should be viewed by God pertains not
only to the usefulness of common life
but even to the truth if religion and
Justice are taken away we then descend
to of the senselessness of the herds
herd animals or the savageness of the
beasts we become the worst of all
animals here we see something that is
kind of uh a reference to Aristotelian
ideas that you know human beings the
best of animals if reasons taken away or
what's distinctive to us we become the
worst of animals but in this case it's
religion that is going to be at the
center of this so lactancius thinks that
religion is really what is distinctive
to us human beings these other things
speech laughter reason and planning
there's some resemblance some similitudo
between human beings and the
non-rational animals but they don't
possess religion wisdom and Justice
which we can possess not necessarily do
possess we have to work towards that so
that's where he thinks the fundamental
division or distinction between humans
and and all the other animals resides